je pense qu'il y à un consensus sur
l'idée selon laquelle lorsqu'il y à une
épizootie une épidémie ou pandémie comme
actuellement d'une soie du rôle de
l'état d'intervenir
les libéraux étaient sur cette ligne dès
le 18e ou 19e siècle mais il ya
intervention et interventions
intervention de l'état elles vont pas
dire à intervenir en permanence ça ne
veut pas dire supplée complètement le
secteur privé comme on a pu le voir ces
derniers mois où on a accusé une
intervention d'état extrêmement forte
tout de même lorsque j'entends monsieur
mauduit vous dire que tout est privatisé
qu'il y à des privatisations dans tous
les domaines moi ce que je constate
c'est qu'on a
l'état providence nous développer au
monde le plus développé au monde
ça n'a pas changé lors de la 15ème à
graver lorsque j'écoute monsieur mauduit
on a véritablement l'impression qu'on
est vrai libéral actuellement qu'il n'y
a plus d'entreprises publiques et que
par exemple pour reprendre les dépenses
étaient notamment les hôpitaux
parmi les pays qui dépense non plus donc
ou lorsque l'on nous parle de secteur
public qui serait à l'abandon et bien il
y a en argent considère dynamique
objectivement en grande partie en pure
perte et qui limite
[Musique]